Now if you think about how security controls need to be preventive, detective, and corrective,
we've been talking about how...
we've been talking about how detective capabilities are provided through IDS and IPS systems.
Now the corrective action that needs to happen after we detect that something is wrong or
against the rules is what this section deals with.
So for example, one of the very first things that we can do is activate sandboxes, and I
know that we've talked about sandboxes before, but a sandbox is like a safe play area.
It's an environment where we can test things, for example, and be able to determine if something
is malicious or not, and that's what we call a sandbox environment.
So one of the things that your IDS, IPS technologies can correct and activate the corrective action
would be to test something in a sandbox environment, and we can determine whether something is either
malicious or not or safe to run in our production environment.
Now when we talk about IDS as an IPS, I think we've talked about this before, however, it's
really important to understand the result that may be returned.
And there are questions on the exam that address this, but basically a IDS slash IPS system
can return what are called false positives and false negatives.
Now don't confuse these with what we talked about in the biometric section, which were
type 1s and type 2s, false rejects and false accepts.
That's not what we're talking about here.
Here the terminology is different, false positives and false negatives.
A false positive is where the IDS system tells us that it is an attack, but in fact it is
not.
And that would actually require the organization to launch into its incident response capability
and at some point determine that it's not a real attack, but we've had to launch into
our incident management capability.
That's a false positive where the IDS system thinks it's an attack, but really isn't.
What's much more critical is what we call a false negative.
This is where the IDS IPS system does not catch something that it should.
And from an organization's perspective, that's much more critical because we should be
catching something that is an issue or an incident, but the IDS IPS system was not able
to do it.
And we've talked about how it's important to fine tune your IDS IPS capabilities so that
we lower, for example, the false positives, but we also try and raise the false negatives.
I mean, we want the IDS IPS system to be as valuable as possible so that it catches everything.
And that requires constant fine tuning so that it returns better decisions on an ongoing
basis.
Now one of the other corrective things that can happen is what a lot of companies have
been focusing on for the last number of years.
And that is to have what are called honeypots and honey nets.
And if you know anything about these, these are fake environments that companies create
to look very attractive so that if an intruder has intruded into your network, you lure
them into these fake environments because they look attractive.
But because they are fake, they can lure these people into those environments so that you
can protect your real environments.
That's the whole purpose of these is to protect your real environments because you're
luring them into fake environments and at the same time, potentially capturing evidence
against the perpetrators.
Now the only difference between honeypot and honeynet is a collection of honeypots.
And what's really important to understand is the legality of these.
Depending on where you put them, they can either be an example of enticement or entrapment.
But the bottom line is companies can use these if someone has already committed a crime.
Someone has already intruded into your network, then we can lure them into these fake environments
and that would be considered to be enticement as opposed to entrapment.
So where you place them is really important part.
And that's what we're trying to highlight here in this very simple network diagram.
The honey nets and the honeypots need to be placed in the right environments so that you
are not entraping individuals but rather enticing them into these fake environments because
they've already done something that is illegal.
And as a final slide here in this section, we need to understand the difference between
enticement and entrapment from a legal perspective.
And this is why we understand that enticement is legal because someone has already committed
a crime and therefore honey nets and honeypots become examples of enticement.
Whereas entrapment would not be legal because you are inducing someone to commit a crime
that they weren't contemplating doing in the first place.
So because they've intruded into your network and then you lure them into your honeypot,
for example, that is an example of enticement.